Saudi Arabia the heart of the Middle
East Saudi has an incredible history an
immersive culture and Saudi hospitality
is legendary today Saudi is also known
as the world's largest oil exporter and
it's also home to the world's largest
green hydrogen project and now home to
the world's first cognitive City Saudi
Arabia is headed towards a new Direction
a new tomorrow a new future that's
powered by
technology in the digital Kingdom I will
tell the story of Saudi Arabia's vision
of entering a new age the age of a
technology-driven future from the
world's largest Smart City developments
to changing the focus of government to
utilize data to drive the economy the
Saudi economic landscape is rapidly
shifting towards technology and
Innovation and what is apparent is with
its incre incredible talent pool future
opportunities and focus on technology
are together going to create a new join
me Yan KH Con in my journey of finding
out what the future holds for Saudi
Arabia as I speak with leading experts
in government the private sector global
technology companies and others to learn
about the evolution of the digital
Kingdom Saudi has a Strate
to make the kingdom the hub for AI
development and AI in general by the
year 2030 some of the organizations that
are responsible for making this happen
are Sadaya the Saudi data and artificial
intelligence agency that was formed just
a few years ago but over the last couple
of years it has made incredible progress
by launching different apps especially
through the pandemic there's a focus uh
to use Technologies such as art
artificial intelligence and of course
Cloud Technologies and others to make
sure this data is utilized to the best
extent to help everyday common people uh
to utilize technology and to benefit so
there is an ecosystem is not just one
single entity so we do have the ndmo the
national data management office which is
the entity that is responsible of
setting the policies drafting the laws
that are related to data and AI to make
sure that we are from the legislative
perspective we are mature enough for the
economy to be developed also there is
the national Center of artificial
intelligence which is the entity that is
responsible of doing the R&D in data and
Ai and developing innovative solutions
to contribute to the economy and take it
to the next level and we have Nic the
national information center which is the
entity that is responsible of developing
and operating Mega data n AI initiatives
that would enable the sector and Sadaya
is the entity that is orchestrating all
of the efforts in a way that we make
sure that we are advancing properly
towards our national Ambitions in data
and air data actually is the new oil
countries now are recognizing the impact
of data and it becomes actually as a
National Asset for them uh through
maximizing uh the data collection and
processing and also generating uh
valuable solution solutions from the
data that data massive data it allowed
us to see at things from not just 10,000
ft but from 100,000 ft we can do all the
data Fusion that is possible to be done
you have the Education data you have
Labor Market data you have commercial
registration data so then you can do all
the data Fusion help decision makers to
get from basic aggregations all the way
to um building machine learning models
that can answer sophisticated questions
all the way to building simulations to
simulate certain policies the
Investments that the kingdom has put in
place when it comes to the digitization
of the kingdom in the past 10 15 years
is paying off now a lot of people were
questioning whether those Investments
back then were the right investment and
the kingdom even doubl down on those
Investments five six years ago when
Vision 2030 was established we were
going even bigger in today's fast
changing world the demands for data
governance data management and
information management in general are
some of the biggest challenges for both
the private as well as the public sector
for governments especially the ability
to efficiently manage citizen data and
citizen information is of the highest
importance and to achieve this
technology ology provides a number of
avenues we see use cases from many
different countries across the world for
huge progress has been made by using
cuttingedge Technologies to manage user
data in fact a number of governments
across the world have started using
decentralized databases such as
blockchain to manage citizen data Saudi
Arabia is leading its efforts to ensure
citizen data is safe and more than
anything else that the highest level of
privacy and data protection are enabled
for any information that is gathered
from citizens this is the core of the
Saudi digital identity program
neat one um domain that we are extremely
proud to be working at is the digital
identity we have developed Neath it's a
single sign on solution so for an
individual user a digital user he has
one credential that he could use to
access multiple applications what do you
get Again by doing that first you make
the journey extremely Pleasant and then
for the applications they don't really
have to incure additional cost because
they really don't have to keep and
maintain identity access Management
Solutions now we have more than 17
million users subscribing to our service
and we have about more than 300 entities
also subscribing to our service so for
those 17 million users they can access
about more than 300 applications using
the same credentials all government
entities plus the private sector are
deeply committed to create the
digitization journey build the
infrastructure there are multiple layers
in this so Nic Sadaya is actually
touching across all these layers
starting from the digital infrastructure
that enables innovators by which we can
monetize this data benefit out of this
data create all these kind of innovative
experiences this means we need to focus
on data quality if this data is not on a
good quality we not achieve the goal at
the end in addition to that SES and
entrepreneurs are not only looking for
open data but we should focus on other
mechanism that helps support them to get
high quality data and utilize this data
to come up with some products or
services that help support society as a
whole data undoubtedly plays a critical
role in everything that happens in our
world today even traffic lights and
Roads generate data and the progress
that Saudi Arabia has made and continues
to make in this domain is extremely
impressive Saudi also handles a very
critical part of a massive amount of
data management in a short duration of
time in the year and that is during the
Journey of Hajj the Islamic pilgrimage
that takes place every year in Saudi
Arabia over 20 million Muslims from
across the world come to Mecca and
managing data and information and that
volume and veracity is a task in its own
this is just one example of how
seriously Saudi Arabia is taking
information and data management and the
whole idea of digital identity very
[Music]
seriously between 2019 and 20121 the
coid 19 pandemic stuck the whole world
it crippled entire countries every
industry across the world was shocked by
the disruption in business and billions
of dollars across the world were
incurred in losses Nations did what they
could to contain the breakout and keep
their citizens safe one key challenge in
this time was the delivery of new
government services and for that it was
necessary to lay down the foundations
for new processes and systems this is
where Saudi Arabia excelled by
developing a new solution talna
literally translating to trust the
release of towaka was one of the fastest
deployments of a Technology based
solution for a country of almost 35
million people when TOA started it was
actually initially just for permission
so people used to apply to ask for
permits for them to move from one place
to another but then over time as the
pandemic gets deeper and deeper
there was a need to create a system that
allows everyone in the country to check
the immunity and the stat the health
status of people and we started building
the team started building uh all these
services to enable all the law
enforcement all the uh Facility Owners
shop owners to check whether this person
got got Corona or not this was the first
service that suddenly became required
Sadaya was able to pull all resources
around with national Information Center
building on the infrastructure building
all the development team creating all
the journeys the team were literally in
Sleepless weeks not nights for almost
two months or so they need to create
these services in very short period of
time and without jeopardizing security
without jeopardizing privacy without
jeopardizing performance and the amount
of support we got from from the top
leadership of the country was tremendous
Saudi is not new to collaboration in
fact it was the vision of modern Saudi
Arabia's founder King Abdul aiz Al sa
who laid the foundation of Saudi
Arabia's economy to collaboration the
partnership with foreign oil companies
led to not only the development of the
oil industry but also to its Skyrocket
marketing growth to the extent that
Saudi Arabia has become one of the
world's largest exporters of oil in the
last eight decades the kingdom continues
the tradition of collaboration and
leading many new initiatives this
includes laying down the foundations of
initiatives such as the digital
cooperation organization a think tank
dedicated to helping countries across
the world take a step into digital
transformation or the establishment of
the future investment Institute a think
tank that was founded in Saudi and now
is a global Organization for investing
into the future Saudi is now home to new
initiatives in the areas of carbon
exchange manufacturing AGR tech
technology climate change and more much
of this is attributed to the initiative
known as Vision 2030 When I visit
countries that have have great ambition
I often ask them are you positioning
yourself not to be good at what you're
doing which you can be but to lead
others to create models for other
communities and other countries this
nation has decided that they want to be
Innovation leaders that they want to be
able to create new ideas and new
solutions that solve problems in the
United States or around this region or
into Africa and it's clear to me looking
around that if the existing
trajectory continues this will be a
formidable Force
globally in just a few years if you read
div Vision 2030 you will find a lot of
things to to be achieved on the
logistics side on the tourism side
healthare education and you name it in
order for the government to be able to
achieve them you have to have a digital
strong robust digital Foundation behind
it listen we cannot build enough data
centers quick enough okay the the the
transformation is massive the farm we
built here is in in partnership with a
company called nadc a national
agriculture development company a
traditional Dairy and juices and other
company that is really trying to
innovate and and and Tech up if you will
and join the new economy right what's
great is we saw NC investing in a 30
megawatt solar power Farm well what we
did is partnered on their land we're
building inside of what used to be alala
crop pivots wasting a lot of water but
they have the water infrastructure and
now we have a a huge scale farm that'll
be producing 140 tons a week of Premium
Tomatoes starting in March 140 tons a
week significant capacity of 16
varieties of tomatoes half of which have
never been tried in the region they're
novel products we're we're changing The
Human Experience in the in the platter
but also at a much lower cost than
Imports very little water consumption
right and it's all made possible by two
partners coming together a traditional
company with infrastructure and US
partnering with that infrastructure with
our our capabilities when it comes to
collaborators def we get to collaborate
with the leading companies in data
artificial intelligence but yes I think
you need to be extremely selective in
what could offer you a better solution
this is very important and when it comes
to benchmarking usually when we get to
develop our strategies whether the
business strategy or the te strategy or
the cyber security strategy we really
work with the best leading consulting
firms to make sure that we get to
Benchmark ourselves and to prop prop ly
set our Ambitions and our goals and to
do to start from where others ended not
from where others started and our vision
is uh to establish the kingdom as a
global leader in the elite lead of the
data and AI driven economy so here in
Riad the digital City we have all the
government entities uh all the offices
and what you see here is a different
kind of energy when it comes to
collaboration when it comes to U meeting
people everything is around here so it's
been incredible meeting different people
from different government entities uh
and talking to them about the actual
change uh that is happening here in
Saudi
[Music]
Arabia I'm here at the Region's largest
technology conference something that
hasn't happened in the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia for many years in fact this
conference called leap is the first of
many of these initiatives that are going
to take place at this conference we're
hearing about trillions of dollars of
investment money into different
initiatives for example technology spend
on artificial intelligence blockchain
connected cars infrastructure
development and many other things Saudi
Arabia is at a critical point right now
because it's focusing more on the data
economy rather than what it's been doing
for the past 8 10 decades is focused on
oil the future of the Saudi Market is
more about leveraging technology to
change everything to change the economy
to change jobs to empower Youth and
communities to build a new kingdom that
powers not just itself but the entire
Middle East right from the beginning of
the different industrial revolutions
automation has been a key factor for
Progress today automation acts as an
accelerator for most Industries
operating in any country Industrial
Automation is highly used in Saudi
Arabia due to its focus on Industries
such as the energy industry and its
various aspects such as upstream and
downstream oil refining petrochemicals
electricity generation and manufacturing
Industries what is the future of
Automation in saudi's fast developing
economy this also opens up the
discussion for thriving cyber security
industry in Saudi Arabia the first step
we do in digitalization is where we move
into we can automate and connect
something it's cheap we automate
everything which is noncore everything
which is core that means you differen
shate on we don't touch you can come
closer to your clients you can have a
more um view from your end to end Supply
Chain management information right you
can have a direct view on where the
product is on your Warehouse you can
manage and control far better these are
important tools for oil and gas these
are important tools for government
sectors to provide better services and
all of this the next step we move into
is that you are the owner of that
information think about in 2 3 years
years I think in Saudi you will hold
your own healthc care record you will
have your information on your taxes on
your services on your cars everything in
one that is totally locked in cyber
secure thing that we need to really work
at is the end user awareness because
regardless how much Investments you have
done in the protecting the
infrastructure and the digital assets if
you have a user with not much awareness
he could be the loophole and many
attacks come through the end users not
through the infrastructure and the
protected infrastructure in today's fast
growing Saudi economy there are multiple
hundreds of billions of dollars of
investment being put into infrastructure
upskilling talent digitalization and
other critical aspects of making Saudi a
global economic leader today the kingdom
has multiple Venture funds that are
creating hundreds of startups and
solving some of the biggest problems in
the world the Saudis are putting their
money where their mouth is you've got
billions of dollars of investment fund
going into entrepreneurship accelerators
and incubators you've got Giga projects
happening we're talking about neom which
has to be one of the biggest projects or
construction projects in the world in
the history of the world $500 billion
financed City and area of the future so
clearly the time is right to bring the
world's most emerging Technologies
futurists impactful people working in
Tech to Saudi Arabia so that they can be
part of this journey and feed into it
one element we see here they Embrace
digitalization like this is a normal
part of their Gene right it just turns
on something for them they're even
excited about it so everything is
connected everything somehow sensed the
early evolution of smart cities is now
turning on the development of cognitive
cities Urban Development is fast
changing the way we live study work and
travel Saudi today has embarked on
multiple Mega infrastructure projects
such as neom the line Red Sea
development and others we are a planet
now that where over half of humanity
lives in cities and that's just going to
grow over the next few years this is
going to be the century of cities and
and all the big issues whether it's
Transportation or energy or the climate
emergency we got to solve these within
cities because this is not just a topic
about our Urban centers this is a topic
about the future of the planet so faced
with some great challenges and all the
promise that cities bring we got to
bring new innovation new ideas new
technologies to apply against these big
problems and you know while we can do
the right thing we ought to do good we
can also do well we can build businesses
we can build new innovation that creates
new solutions for communities all over
the world look at the end of the day
smart cities is about quality of life
it's about a better Human Experience for
everybody a huge majority of Saudis are
youth with approximately 37% under the
age of 14 51% of the Kingdom's
population is under the age of 25 with
such an incredible talent pool of future
generation economic contributors Saudi
is sitting on a resource that many
nations are currently struggling with
the kingdom is home to institutes such
as the King Abdullah University of
Science and Technology and King Fahad
University of petroleum and minerals to
name a few some of the world's top
talent is now teaching faculty at these
institutions and the quality of learning
and gaining skills To Build A Better
Tomorrow are second to none Saudi is
truly undergoing a new technology and
education Revolution it's very
interesting time in Saudi Arabia with
vision 203 and all of the digital
initiatives that's happening there is a
lot of investment in terms of talent and
job creation for the skills of the
future MCI the ministry of information
and telecommunication is investing a lot
in in a huge initiative that targets the
skills of the future for Saudi uh locals
and for the citizens what we are doing
at Microsoft as well part of that
direction is we have managed to train
more than 100,000 students in iot AI
cloud computing and others we're also
working very closely uh with the
governments and organizations to uh also
train and stimulate the work of
technical uh people so definitely data
and AI opened many opportunities and by
the way the opportunities are not only
technical there is also the
opportunities related to governance and
policies by enhancing the maturity or
the legislative maturity data and
artificial intelligence you will open
more opportunities for people to work in
this field like having lawyers in data
and artificial intelligence having legal
experts in data artificial intelligence
policy experts are we doing really uh a
good job when it comes to building those
universities choosing the disciplines
that your those University should focus
on how can we make sure that those
universities the output of those
universities very much aligned with what
the labor market needs and so the idea
is that we work with the Ministry of
Education we work with the ministry of
human resources and Social Services to
do such evaluation and the result
results were you know very surprising to
many we enable those universities to to
um use such insights to help them make
uh bitter uh decisions when it comes to
the Investments that they will make one
of the
characteristics of this great nation of
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia right now is
that it has a very large and growing
young
population and they have a chance
to create a new future to bring new
ideas to the table they need to create
and be engaged in the type of future
that they want so that means expanding
education to include things like
software development programming like
we're seeing all over the world this is
already happening of course giving as
many children as possible access to the
different tools that can enable them to
be inspired to understand things like
science technology engineering
mathematics applied uh to solve the
great problems of a great nation
countries want to create environments
where the young population and the new
working population don't feel like they
have to look elsewhere for the great
opportunities that they are here at home
and that means investing in our kids
investing in their education inspiring
them and really believing what they can
do to create a uh a a prosperous future
for this land I'm quite used to going to
Tech events in different countries and
one of the most arresting things about
Saudi is the fact that you have such a
large proportion of female visitors to
this event and the tech industry in
Saudi Arabia has 28% female
participation at this moment in time and
that is an upwards Trend and it's
growing that is leading World leading in
terms of other
countries Saudi today is headed towards
the future with no stops perhaps the
next few years will be a revelation for
the rest of the world as Saudi doubles
down on its technology Investments its
focus on developing its talent pool and
potentially becoming a Powerhouse of
different Industries and a hub in the
Middle East all of the sectors that we
are working at be Health be
energy can be definitely affected by
data and artificial intelligence even
the renewable
energy uh in
fact we are working now in the energy
and the health sector trying to use data
and AI techniques to advance those
sectors so we believe that data and AI
could be key to many of our challenges I
can say openly Saudi is serious about
this they have realized the need for
economic diversification and for having
the Saudi people participate both in the
value creation and the value capture of
technology and to improve the lives of
of you know Saudi consumers Saudi Market
participants Etc so people will see you
know the transformation and the economic
growth of Saudi as a very real thing it
will entice them to commit to the region
and to commit to the country as we have
we're actively here our largest asset
anywhere is built here because we
acknowledge the size of the market we
see the opportunity we found like-minded
Partners like in nadc and NC's partly
owned by the public investment fund
right all the way up to the leadership
here there you really see appetite for
change and I think that excites people
like me and entrepreneurs who want to
make an impact and want to build
something exciting the Middle East is
the new Europe particularly when looking
at the demographics of this region and
there's almost 500 million young people
in the Middle East you know people under
the age of 30 the promise and potential
around this region is enormous and
serious amounts of investment into
getting this youth into technical jobs
stem jobs into technology so I think
you're going to see a hub programming
you know a hub for cyber security
Excellence a hub for gaming and uh you
know software engineering it's very
exciting and it's definitely a place of
growth Saudi Arabia is creating the
largest Esports arena in the world right
now I see Saudi Arabia becoming the next
big hub for Esports it will be the
future for gaming we're the biggest
economy in the Middle East we are the
largest oil transport in the world so we
do have a big responsibility we are also
the the Islamic destination for a big
Muslim Nation lot of responsibility on
Saudi Arabia and I think we are standing
up to this responsibility and continue
to drive this change in the region we
continue to be the backbone of the
Middle
[Music]
East the future is ever so Elusive and
unpredictable but very much available to
us in plain sight if we choose to look
at the right signals the world today is
at a Crossroads between fighting disease
that transcends Nations Wars that are
crippling the global economy and
unpredictable financial and other events
that impact not just one country but
everyone across the world Saudi Arabia
is moving fast towards a new vision
Vision 2030 and has invested
significantly in its infrastructure and
Technology the next few years are going
to be the beginning of a new era the era
of the digital Kingdom my journey as a
filmmaker takes me to places where the
story is not breaking but where
breakthroughs are happening and where
massive changes are happening in the
future the digital Kingdom has been made
possible by the trust and help of a lot
of people and we thank everyone who was
part of this journey a big thanks to
informa Michael champion Annabelle
Mander and the team that hosted us at
leap I'd also like to thank the
leadership team at Sadaya who were
extremely generous with their time with
us and everyone who took the time to
interview with us and lastly those who
believe that Saudi Arabia is an
incredible place to
be